first stream in a while we'll let people
get connected going to be mostly
focusing on two things number one
breaking revelations that Donald Trump
also personally met with Sergey kiss
lack the Russian ambassador to the
United States during the campaign
absolute blockbuster revelations okay
going to be talking about that also
going to talk about the Republican plan
to repeal and replace the Affordable
Care Act known colloquially as Obamacare
okay so those are going to be the two
main topics of discussion today I will
wait a couple of minutes to get people
connected to the stream remember to
follow me on Instagram there was some
really interesting stuff over the
weekend I had a jam session with former
producer louis and a picture of it was
posted to my Instagram account which is
david pakman and people reacting very
strongly very very strongly to that
picture so check it out make sure to
give me a follow on instagram at david
dot pakman will also be doing live shout
outs and thank yous to people who sign
up for membership at david pakman.com
slash membership during the stream here
and i'll be on for a bit i'll take
questions super chat is on etc etc you
can get a discount off of membership uh
with the coupon code i voted 17 and
anybody who signs up that's the number
one funding source for the show anybody
who signs up during the stream at david
pakman.com slash membership i will give
a lot a live shout out and thank you
people asking if i read the chat during
the streams i keep an eye on it uh the
best way to if you have a question is to
use super chat otherwise i will try to
check in on on the the chat absolutely
and rule in court getting started early
with super chat sending a two dollar
super chat thank you saying shout out
from a lien and ii love your stuff David
thank you very much much appreciated uh
okay so let's dig into the first topic
here it
now been revealed that Donald Trump
personally met with the Russian
ambassador sergey kiss li act during the
campaign this is controversial for a
number of reasons not the least of which
Don is that Donald Trump repeatedly
denied having met with any Russian
officials as a candidate denied it
appears to be true okay report from
Think Progress sourcing from a number of
different news outlets including the
wall street journal which was owned by
News Corporation the parent company of
fox news as well as America blog let's
just look at the article together okay
this is from thinkprogress.org Donald
Trump has claimed repeatedly that he has
had no contact with Russian officials as
a presidential candidate he was lying
says this article Trump personally met
with the Russian ambassador on april 20
7 2016 prior to a major foreign policy
speech the wall street journal and a
report that was little noticed at the
time but was recently picked up by
America blog reported the meeting last
year quote a few minutes before he made
those remarks mr. Trump met at a VIP
reception with Russia's ambassador to
the US Sergey Ivanovitch his leic mr.
Trump warmly greeted mr. kiss liac and
three other foreign ambassadors who came
to the reception this was not a big deal
at the time and as is pointed out by the
think progress article it wasn't heavily
reported on because it wasn't clear this
was going to be such a big deal at the
time now that we know that the National
Security Advisor michael Flynn resigned
in shame after lying repeatedly about
the subject matter of his conversation
with the Russian ambassador after Jeff
Sessions the Trump Attorney General has
also been caught being deceptive about
meetings with Russian officials now this
is a far bigger deal there are pictures
of the Russian ambassador at this event
taking his seat with former US Secretary
of State James Baker there is absolutely
no question that Trump was there there
is absolutely no question that the
Russian
basa der was there and there have been
no refutation thus far of what is now a
months-old report about the fact that
they met there's another this so that's
like the big headline here okay there's
another aspect of this that is not being
reported on as much which is that now
Attorney General then Senator Jeff
Sessions was also reportedly at this
meeting and what this means is that the
the deception we now know jeff Sessions
participated in where he said I didn't
meet with anyone it turns out that we
know he met with Sergey kiss Lee act
twice this would actually make it three
times that the Attorney General jeff
Sessions met with Sergey kiss Lee act by
my count if I'm understanding the think
progress story and the cited Wall Street
Journal and americablog stories
correctly that means that the deception
that we recently found out about from
jeff sessions regarding these meetings
is incomplete there was actually a third
meeting okay so this is major in I
hesitate to use the phrase because I use
it a lot this is major in any number of
ways we're going to be covering this
tomorrow on the show let me be let's see
how clear I can be here about this
meeting with ambassadors to the US is
not in and of itself suspicious or
controversial or indicative of any
problem when you try to conceal it and
lie about it it becomes a problem when
numerous members of your cabinet are
involved in the deception it becomes a
bigger problem and when it all relates
to the Ambassador from the same country
that intelligence estimates uh indicate
was involved in hacking to help you win
when you have connections involving at
this point I can't even do it all right
i mean we've done assume it so many
times I won't do it but when you take
all the circumstances in total now all
of a sudden the meetings that your staff
lied about are a big deal okay are a big
deal we will be talking about that
morrow in detail thank you too Carl
Jane's who just signed up for a david
pakman show member membership that is at
david pakman.com slash membership
memberships are the number one funding
source for the show most of what we do
is funded by memberships and we do have
a coupon code which is i voted 17 that's
available to you lots of great benefits
to being a member including that we do a
daily what's called the bonus show just
for our paid subscribers you also get
the full one-hour show every day instead
of getting it chopped up into three to
five minute segments like we do on
YouTube released every 90 minutes around
four o'clock eastern you get the full
hour show minus the commercials which
leaves about 51 minutes uh you get that
by about four o'clock no waiting for a
three to five minute clip to publish
every 90 minutes okay so please do sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership
use the coupon code if you want again
it's i voted 17 and I will be continuing
live shout outs and thank-yous including
I will do one more before we move on uh
to Jan Frank who signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership also using
the the big lee tremendous coupon code
ok obviously tomorrow we're also going
to be talking about and i want to pull
up some of the notes I've already made
about this we're going to be talking
about the Republican plan to replace the
Affordable Care Act known colloquially
to some as Obamacare okay there's a lot
in the plan that is not surprising and
what's not surprising is for example
number one that a lot of the provisions
of the Affordable Care Act are part of
their calling it the American Health
Care Act I think that it makes sense to
call it Trump care at this point it's
Trump's okay whatever happens from now
on is Trump's in a sense it's dead on
arrival okay because the new proposal
from Republicans shares so many
characteristics with the Affordable Care
Act there are many self-described
conservative Republicans that are saying
absolutely we're not doing this and
there are also of course Democrats that
are saying you're getting rid of the
individual man
date and the employer mandate which are
sort of necessary in order to pay for
this entire thing so it it in a sense
it's being said that this initial
proposal is dead on arrival I have
another sort of hypothesis as to what's
going on here and interestingly enough k
lima kennedy the trump supporter CNN
commentator suggested something similar
today which is the that we are starting
here with the most extreme version of
the proposal and eventually there's
going to be some kind of renegotiation
and changes will be made and it'll be
made more palatable to conservatives and
maybe a few bones will be thrown towards
the Democrats as well to end up with
what it is that Donald Trump actually
wants to pass okay that's one idea that
has been proposed here it's
fundamentally an issue of math okay if
you want to keep most of the provisions
like of the Affordable Care Act but you
don't want to keep the mechanism to pay
for it which is everybody has to have
insurance what will happen well you will
have a natural movement in the direction
of healthier people not having insurance
and sick less healthy people having the
insurance what does that mean if the
average insurance customer and I hate
that their customers but that's what
they are in our system the average
insurance customer will be less healthy
meaning they are more expensive for
insurance companies meaning that
premiums will have to go up to cover
those people in addition when you have
fewer insured people uninsured people
who have a problem go to the emergency
room which is also really expensive
that's priced in as well to health
insurance premiums it's priced into
health care costs etc so it's it's a
non-starter mathematically we're going
to wait for the Congressional Budget
Office to score this and tell us well
what is going to be the the financial
impact of this what's going to be the
financial cost of this but there it's
it's absolutely stunning that we've seen
over the last six maybe even 12 months
the increased popularity of the
provisions of the Affordable Care Act
that many people don't even realize our
parts of the Affordable Care Act yet no
intellectual understanding that the only
way that this works mathematically is if
everyone is covered okay we've got five
dollars super chat from Isaiah row who
says do you think that the US will have
universal health care within our
lifetimes it seems like eventually there
must be a breaking point I wish I could
be more optimistic about that question
Isaiah and thank you by the way for
sending the super chat super chat is on
and happening the US was actually moving
in the direction of what we would call
universal or single-payer health care
early in the 20th century and wendell
potter former Cigna executive wendell
potter actually talks about this in his
book deadly spin which i highly
recommend and it's on my list of
recommendations at david pakman.com
slash recommendations he talks about how
the US was actually moving in the
direction of a national health care
system and then after world war one
before World War two for PR reasons
because it sounded too similar to what
was going on in Germany at the time the
u.s. bailed on going in the direction of
single-payer health care and you sort of
know the rest of the story which is we
got what we have which is a so-called
market-based or or as I call it for
profit or health care inc solution and
you know where that system is so
ingrained in American society at this
point not in a good way in a bad way in
all of the worst aspects the kleptocracy
the oleg are key the taking taking areas
of society that should be in the commons
out of the commons and putting them into
the profit side the profit motive that
i'm not at all confident we're going to
see single-payer or universal health
care or like a medicare-for-all type of
plan during our lifetimes because it
depends how long our lifetimes are right
a big thank you to yulia wilson yulia
wilson has just signed up for a David
Pakman show membership at david pakman
calm slash membership she opted not to
use the coupon code which gives you
forty percent off which is a major huge
huge discount no matter whether you pay
full price or not even if you use the
coupon code I voted 17 and you say forty
percent on the price you still get one
hundred percent of the benefits and
that's a really great thing okay so
please sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership and please if you sign up
check out the march second bonus show
this is one of our most popular bonus
shows that we've done and in that bonus
show I tell a story about the david
pakman show was almost scammed in a way
and on the march second bonus show I go
into the story and I tell it so I
recommend one of the first bonus shows
you should check out when you sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership with
or without the coupon code is the march
second bonus show we've got a ten dollar
super chat from DW Washburn thank you no
question no comment but I do appreciate
the super chat no doubt about that some
of the other stories I'm looking at for
tomorrow okay we have two Republicans
who now have signed up signed on to
demanding the tax returns of President
Trump this is something I'm obviously in
favor of I think of all the presidents
over the last 40 years the all the
others we've seen their tax returns
Trump is probably the guy we most
desperately need to see the tax returns
up so there are it's been a partisan
split Democrats saying we should see
those tax returns Republicans saying
that that's not really a big deal we do
have now two Republicans that have
signed on to that demand to see Donald
Trump's tax return so we will probably
be talking about that on tomorrow's show
also going to be talking about this is
so funny there's been a number of pseudo
scandals that have plagued the david
pakman show over the last several weeks
one is the revelation from david pakman
show producer pat that he uses a keurig
to make coffee at home and that really
shook the audience in many ways and
check out some of the threads on our
reddit discussion forum about this
david pakman.com slash reddit there's a
new scandal which I'm calling spit gate
there's been a video from a recent live
stream that I did uh where it appears as
though I spit and not like a tiny bit
but like a significant amount of saliva
flew out of my mouth during an agitated
moment on a live stream when I was
sitting right here and uh there's been a
wonderful viewer of the show who has
isolated that guy and put that on a on a
repeating loop in an animated image and
that is a controversy that now I am
going to have to address on the program
and by the way i think that the video
may have been tampered with i think it
may have been a visual artifact that has
been exaggerated in post-production but
spit gate we may have time for that
tomorrow I'm not totally sure yet I'm
also going to talk about something I
call filling the swamp you probably have
heard by now that Donald Trump talked
about draining the swamp getting rid of
lobbyists being an outsider
anti-establishment type of guy blah blah
blah we know that the opposite is
actually what's happened but we've been
looking at some of those ethics rules
anti lobbyists rules that Trump has
passed and as it turns out although
Donald Trump has received the PR benefit
of passing some of these were blocking
the ability of lobbyists to do XYZ we
have evidence to suggest that Trump is
just ignoring those rules so yes Donald
Trump did pass some of those rules
regarding lobbyists that he promised to
pass but he's just ignoring them and
nobody really is holding him accountable
for that so we're going to do that
tomorrow okay that that's a story we're
going to deal with tomorrow we have a
ten-dollar super chat from Isaiah row
who says have you seen secular talks
video where he thinks there's a
connection between lower Democratic
approval and talk about Russia he thinks
the Russia talk is becoming a
distraction for the real issues I have
not seen Kyle's video on that let's see
if I go over to his channel right now I
don't know how
this is hmm I'm not seeing it in his
most recent videos ah as Democrats yell
about Russia their favorability to
clines uh I don't know that you you may
have a correlation you have to be
careful if you have correlation to
ensure that there is causation if you're
gonna make some inferences about that
and I don't know what the causal case
that Kyle is making is but I will check
it out it's interesting that that he
brings that up I think that there's no
doubt that the Russia talk is
distracting from discussion of bills and
legislation if you're Republicans that's
good because they've been passing insane
stuff and I talked about this yesterday
in a video called Trump distractions
Republicans continue destroying America
so we're talking about that but yes
there's definitely some a distraction
going on that the thing is I am I guess
you could say in disagreement with some
on the left and in agreement with some
on the left I believe that the Russia
situation is a scandal i think it is an
absolutely utterly an insane scandal of
objective significant importance and i'm
glad to talk about that you know with
whoever wants to talk about it but that
that's where I am on that issue let's do
a couple more thank yous members
continue to flow in david pakman.com
slash membership many using the coupon
code i voted 17 christopher smith
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code i voted
17 also crystal hefner crystal hefner
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code i voted
17 which is you get forty percent off
when you do that okay I mean that you
get a hundred percent of the benefits
for forty percent off and it's the
number one funding source for the show
you probably realize by now there's no
ever been a more important time to fund
alternatives to corporate media we have
a two British Pound super chat from
Karen Jones saying what has happened
about illegal boating nonsense haven't
heard much from Trump about it have you
let me just pause there we do have to
block a couple people and I am going to
get to this there's just such every once
in a while I realized that there's a lot
of nonsense going on in the in the chat
and i'm just going to block a few people
the block button is free so I'm not not
afraid to use it uh yeah you you've
noticed that the the discussion of the
three to five million supposedly illegal
votes that were done by a combination of
undocumented immigrants as well as
people registered twice by the way
Donald one of Donald Trump's daughters
was registered in two states to vote uh
Steve Bannon was registered in two
states to vote trying to think who else
a number of people uh that we found out
were registered in two states nothing
illegal about being registered in two
states as long as you only vote in one
of them I'm pretty sure I'm registered
in two locations although both in the
same state anyway yeah the Trump's moved
on to the latest shiny object that
floated by in the background and by that
shiny objects for Trump usually mean
whatever's on Fox News or Breitbart and
that is uh it there's a constant sort of
misinformation campaign disinformation
campaign that's going on but it's very
hard to identify many times what is that
what is the objective of distraction
what are what is the Trump
administration trying to distract from
and in this particular case it's not
totally clear but it's pretty damn clear
that the entire thing with with the
three to five million votes was a
pretext to pass restrictions on voter ID
and voter registration type restrictions
and I expect to see that come back
around there's just a lot going on right
now we have a five dollar and 57 sent
super chat from game fire 74 who says
how concerned should we be about the
special election in Montana Republicans
trying to squash mail-in voting efforts
what
can non Montana residents do you know I
don't know that much about the Montana
special election let me pull that up
right now and see what that's all about
we have an at-large congressional
district special election incumbent
representative Ryan zinke was nominated
by President Trump as US Secretary of
the Interior and confirmed so he
resigned on march first and that has
created a special election that has to
be held at least 85 but not more than a
hundred days after the vacancy is
created very very interesting situation
there I don't know much about it I
promised to look into it and to report
back we have a two-dollar super chat
from Felipe Garcia who says who will be
the first anti-trump Republican member
of Congress it depends on what you mean
by anti-trump because we've already seen
pretty significant criticism of a lot of
the things that Donald Trump has done
from different members of Congress
Lindsey Graham is one John McCain is
another we've seen sporadic critiques
and now with the release of the
Republican version of Obamacare which
shares a lot of the same provisions and
also has some pretty significant
differences you're seeing more
Republicans say this just isn't going to
happen we're just you we're not going to
vote for this and it's just not going to
be able to it's just not going to happen
so i think that there's already a list
of Republicans that are saying you know
we're not loving a lot of what Trump is
doing and there's no doubt that there
are going to be more no doubt about it
big thank you to Christian Hayes as well
as Richard Kendall david pakman show
members who signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership uh I can't
tell you how important it is for people
to sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership and i can't tell you how
inspired i was that in February we set a
record for new members in a single month
prior to this past februari the month
that just ended a week ago
single month record for new members was
just over 200 something like 205 or
something like that we had 523 new
members sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership during februari many of
you during these live streams many of
you using the forty percent coupon code
I voted 17 and we are on track actually
potentially potentially to surpass that
during March so big things happening i
will keep doing live shoutouts and thank
yous for people who sign up during the
stream the coupon code i voted 17 okay
so very very exciting i saw a couple of
questions flowing by in the chat people
asking that I know that Trump met with
the Russian ambassador yeah that's the
the title for this live stream Trump met
with Russian ambassador and it's the
first thing I discussed on the stream so
you can rewind the entire thing will be
made available after the fact okay so
please you can check that out people
saying why are others talking about
former producer louis at the beginning
of the stream I mentioned that I had a
jam session where I play drums former
producer Louis played guitar david
pakman show at our attorney played a
guitar it was a great jam session and I
posted a picture of it to my Instagram
account i'm david pakman on instagram so
please follow me on instagram check out
that picture also i talked about this on
the show today let me pull it up
actually just for myself i posted a
picture yesterday or the day before of
two hilarious billboards that are side
by sarwar side by side in boston they've
since been pulled down one is for an app
that tells you where to find um uh
marijuana dispensaries and the Billboard
next to it is a billboard advocating
that there is evidence for God and
citing an 800 number that you can call
which is really really funny and then
also people talking about my new dog on
Instagram that's not my dog that's my
dad's dog but I did post a picture of
Nemo Pakman who is an English lab
at my instagram account david pakman so
check that out uh okay we have a 100 I
believe it's a 100 swedish kronor super
chat from it nomad polymath saying cool
show on the Swedish woman worried that
Trump statements and foxes experts are
empowering our own alright in conspiracy
theories what you're taking what do you
think we could do about it yes major
major drama in Sweden going on here uh
you I don't know if you follow the story
but we updated it today and we have a
new video going live about it at UH 1030
p.m. eastern time tonight after Donald
Trump referred to this completely
imaginary what happened in Sweden thing
nothing happened in Sweden Trump sort of
alluding to some kind of attack in
Sweden Bill O'Reilly on on what was it
on uh last week I don't remember the day
brought on a supposed Swedish national
security expert named Neil's built and
it turns out nobody in Sweden has heard
of this guy as a national security
expert turned out the guy hadn't even
been in Sweden for something like 23
years fake right actual an actual fake
expert yesterday we learned and I talked
about it on the show today that uh this
guy was on o'reilly show Neil's built
talking about dangerous criminal
immigrants he is a dangerous criminal
immigrant he came to the United States
and was convicted of two or three
different crimes which I talked about to
wreck today uh and it's endlessly
endlessly hilarious that he is a
representation of what he pretended to
be an expert in okay in any case um yes
Sweden's all right we're seeing all
right type movements rise in uh a number
of European countries and I've talked
about it and I've talked in those
segments about what individuals can do
to sort of push back against it and
we're gonna talk about it again on the
show so thank you for that we have a two
british pound super chat from bewildered
kettle asking what caused dave rubin to
become such a [ __ ] I don't have an
answer to that i I've taught me Dave
Rubens a friend of mine
I've made it abundantly clear and I I
don't hide this from Dave I agree with
him on many issues I disagree with him
on many issues what else can i say i end
to avoid the ad homonyms but some people
gravitate to them not me i would love to
either have Dave on or be on his show
soon and talk about areas where we
disagree in areas areas where we agree
big thank you to josh wilson as well as
lowell Steiger both Josh and Lowell have
signed up for memberships at david
pakman.com slash membership that's the
number one number one funding source for
the david pakman show and you have a
coupon code which will give you forty
percent off if you type it in it is i
voted 17 all one word all lower case hey
i see a few people in the chat talking
about dave rubin and fox news I somebody
emailed me about that and I haven't
looked into it yet can somebody tell me
what's going on with dave rubin and fox
news i've not heard about is he has it
was he on fox news or I just don't know
what it is that people are talking about
I don't know if somebody in the chat can
explain what did it with the dave rubin
appear on fox news or has he been hired
by fox news i don't know not seeing
anything about it oh yes he's regularly
on redeye Brendan Murphy says oh okay
yeah I've never seen that show so that's
not something I would be aware of all
right we've got a ten-dollar super chat
from Giovanni Anthony nap saying hey
David how do we fight against all the
gas lighting on the TV when gas lighting
became so extreme I feel as if we are
loosing people and not gaining enough to
our cause because of it sad ! listen i
love it i love the reference to sad i
don't understand the question I
genuinely don't understand the question
we've talked about gas lighting a little
bit but I don't know are we losing
people and not gaining enough because of
gas lighting on the TV I'm sorry I just
don't understand the question I truly do
I truly do apologize about that if you
can clarify in the chat I'll try to see
the chats moving pretty quickly folks
but i'll try to see what it was that you
meant giovanni but i'm not understanding
that hmm okay well sorry about that
maybe maybe it'll pop up again yeah some
people are trying to explain people are
falling for manipulations of the gas
lighting David I think he's saying
whether or not it's effective
manipulating someone by psychological
means into questioning their own sanity
that's an explanation of gas lighting
yeah I'm sorry folks I don't understand
exactly what the question is there okay
a few other stories I'm looking at for
tomorrow Solar is now providing twice as
many jobs as the coal industry major
story not only because of what it means
about alternative energy but also
because of the continued exposing abdon
'old Trump's energy ideas as absolutely
and totally laughable other countries
are laughing at us China is moving way
ahead on alternative energy India's
moving way ahead an alternative energy
and meanwhile Trump wants to revive coal
okay absolute absolutely atrocious I
want to talk about that scientists have
categorized earth as a toxic planet
that's a story i'm looking at for
tomorrow Donald Trump has blamed
President Obama for a hundred and twenty
two vicious Guantanamo prisoners that
have returned to the battlefield turns
out 113 of those hundred and twenty two
vicious Guantanamo prisoners were
actually released under george w bush so
as usual Donald Trump wrong on the facts
and wrong about just about everything
I'm looking at that story for tomorrow
and here's another one that sorry I just
hit my camera there's another story i'm
looking at for tomorrow which relates to
a Donald Trump Hotel in Azerbaijan where
it appears as though Iran is involved so
this is not this could be in direct
business that Donald Trump did with Iran
by the way a country that's on is Muslim
majority immigration ban list
and we're going to be looking into that
it appears that the Iranian
Revolutionary Guard was very tied into
this Azerbaijani hotel for Donald Trump
absolutely and utterly insane right I
mean it's just I've said it before I
know people are getting upset that I
that I use this phrase but you can't
write this stuff you really can't write
this stuff some of the headlines some of
the most popular discussions from our
reddit discussion forum I hope you'll
join us over on reddit we have a great
community there of just under 3,000 of
our viewers david pakman.com slash read
it there are a couple of interesting
posts going on one is pointing to i want
to say something more about this okay
there's a post from what there's a post
linking to an article from The
Washington Post pointing out that Hitler
published a list of crimes committed by
groups he didn't like and that Donald
Trump has recently done that if you've
been watching my show show for a while
you know that I am against saying
anything is like Hitler unless it's
actually like Hitler I'm against saying
anything is like Nazis unless it's
actually like Nazis there are a number
of similarities right now between pre
World War two germany and the united
states and 2017 that's different than
saying Trump is Hitler I've never said
that I don't believe that that should be
said at this point in time because i
don't believe that the facts bear that
out but there is no doubt that there are
notable similarities between what's
going on now and pre-world War to
Germany for people asking for details we
are working on a video on exactly that
issue okay so we will absolutely be
talking about that we have a number of
threads at david pakman.com slash reddit
about the new replacement bill for the
Affordable Care Act from Republicans I'm
going to jump into some of those
discussions after i get out of the live
stream we also have a post which is
simply deliver liberals believe in open
borders or rather do liberals believe in
borders period
and a pretty interesting discussion you
might think that it's a deliberate
attempt to troll it's actually not and a
pretty interesting discussion is
starting there so check all of that out
david pakman.com slash reddit we have a
ten-dollar super chat from mazepa z
mazeppa z i'm not sure how to pronounce
that what are your thoughts on farmers
trying to deregulate using fertilizers
there is a plethora of research on how
to do safe farming why don't they yeah
up it really comes down to profit okay
it really comes down to profit and for
the most part you're looking at the
profit motive when you look at big
farming in the United States I actually
recently read quite a bit quite a bit
about big farming not to be confused
with big pharma in the United States and
most of what's going on now you had a
situation where at a certain point you
either had to choose I'm jumping on with
industrialized farming or I'm going to
go in a completely different direction a
much more uphill battle a far less
profitable direction and because of big
farming you've seen a lot of farmers who
otherwise would not have been inclined
to go in the direction of big
agriculture who were sort of pushed in
that direction and I don't know the
specifics of that story but generally
speaking just about everything going on
in farming right now is based on money
and if you're talking about farming and
and pesticides there is no doubt about
it $5.00 super chat from stephen ernst
key hey David how far away do you think
we are from elected a president that is
openly atheist when do you think we as a
nation will accept this it's going to be
a while it's going to be a while because
a recent poll I believe showed that
actually communist is seen less
negatively than being an atheist in the
United States overall or at least in the
context of politics so I think it's
going to be a while I don't think that
it's going to be any time
and there's still a lot of stigma
attached to just saying I'm an atheist
even though you know it's not crazy to
think that President Obama was not
nearly as religious as he says I don't
believe for a second that Trump is
religious he's been pandering constantly
about his belief in God in the Bible
thank God for this that God bless all
that stuff so i think that there's
definitely still time before we actually
see that just someone say hey I'm an
atheist and be elected okay also from
our reddit discussion forum there is a
thread call this is just funny Patrick
Ulysses Ford we had a voicemail
yesterday on the show where there was a
suggestion from a viewer that our little
titles on the show have our middle
initials my middle initial Pat's middle
initial and I said I don't have a middle
initial okay and as a result of that I'm
not going to have such a middle initial
but Pat if you want to tell us what your
middle name is by all means go ahead and
Pat refuse to tell us what his middle
name was and it's caused a firestorm
we're now they're speculation one person
suggesting on reddit that it's patrick
Ulysses Ford someone else saying that
it's keurig Patrick curing Ford which of
course is a reference to curate gate
from from a week or two ago someone
suggesting that it's Wendell Patrick
Wendell Ford or Pat C Ford sort of an
analogous to Patsy Ford an implication i
guess that pat is a patsy of sorts on
the david pakman show not really sure
exactly what that would mean very very
funny that that's going a lot of people
liking the entire pat middle name thing
which by the way i think is a total
distraction i think there is nothing
there's no there there I think there's
no problem whatsoever with what's going
on with Pats middle name big thank you
to Cheryl Walker who signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership cheryl used
the coupon code i voted 17 which gave
her a forty percent discount please sign
up it's our number one source of funding
we talked about Trump meeting
the Russian ambassador at the beginning
when this stream ends you can rewind and
go back to the beginning we also talked
about the Republican plan to replace the
Affordable Care Act it's a disaster it
makes no sense we'll be talking about
that in more detail tomorrow thanks to
everybody for joining me and I will
indeed do another livestream very very
soon